pose mon col merci d'être avec nous sur
arte france en direct ce soir alors on
l'a vu jean yves le drian souhaitent des
réformes concrètes en le vivant est ce
que la france peut prouver que provoquer
une résolution ou en tout cas un début
de résolution de crise au liban
bonsoir à tous enfin comme ça a été dit
dans vos reportages le liban passe
aujourd'hui par une des périodes les
plus dramatiques de son histoire
économie sociale monétaire et à tous les
niveaux
aujourd'hui tous les secteurs les
secteurs publics le secteur privé a été
longtemps un fer de lance un pylône
central de l'économie libanaise étant
est enseignements finalement pour
répondre à votre question oui on a de
l'espoir de la visite du ministre
français
on a de l'espoir mais en même temps on a
peur on a peur parce qu'on a vu que nos
gouvernements tous les gouvernements qui
se sont succédé sur les trente dernières
années
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'on
reçoit une aide ou un projet d'un
international mais pour rappel on a eu
la france qui a toujours été aux côtés
du liban qui a organisé en 2001 la
conférence de paris un suivi de paris de
suivi de paris iii au passé à côté les
conférences de stockholm de londres de
bruxelles de rome et finalement aucune
des réformes promises
aucune des promesses de réformes qui ont
été faits par tous les gouvernements qui
se sont succédés n'ont pu les mettre en
place et dernièrement la conférence de
sède en 2019 qui finalement une
conférence qui sera appelée conférence
des réformes avec les entreprises
on n'a vu aucune réforme aucune
attention spéciale qui a été l'hôte de
données par toute la classe politique et
jeudi toute la classe politique qui
gouverne depuis plus de 30 ans et qui a
finalement a détruit un pays durant
quinze ans dans une guerre fratricide et
qui la north tri socialement et
économiquement sur 30 ans de règne
donc oui on a espoir on parle d'une
réforme structurelle pour que le fmi
accorde cette aide de 10 milliards
d'euros
plusieurs camps s'opposent sur cette
réforme
concrètement en quoi elle consiste à
cette réforme structurelle et pourquoi
ça bloque
regardez pourquoi les réformes ce n'est
pas une réforme c'est plusieurs réformes
la première réforme est la plus
importante d'abord c'est la référente de
l'électricité du liban qui coûte 1
hier au gouvernement donc 2 milliards de
dollars et n'a pas été réformé depuis
plus de 30 ans aujourd'hui la deuxième
c'est la sécurité et la révision des
frontières nous savons que l'entrée de
toutes nos frontières malheureusement ne
sont pas sécurisées ce soit la frontière
terrestre vers la série qui permet à des
produits d'aller devenir de tous genres
la frontière maritime qui n'est pas
surveillée donc il s'est beaucoup moins
de rentrées à l'état sur un deuxième
plus et 2 et 2 3 bien sûr la corruption
la corruption galopante et a finalement
a dérobé tous et font tous ces fonds
internationaux plus de 50 ou 60
milliards qui sont venus sur tous les
pays
notre demande en tout cas à l'état
français notre demande au fmi parce que
nous en tant que secteur privé les
bénévoles a reçu de demande
c'est d'aider directement les secteurs
productive si on n'arrive pas à arrêter
l'hémorragie au secteur public parce que
pour rappel c'est les mêmes personnes
mêmes pouvoirs politiques qui en place
depuis plus de 30 ans si on ne peut pas
arrêter les robes l'hémorragie au moins
les sont le coeur battre et le coeur
c'est les secteurs productifs libanais
voilà pourquoi la première réponse qu'on
a vraiment accueilli avec joie a été un
support aux écoles et des bourses
scolaires
on espère pouvoir avoir de cette visite
un support aux secteurs productifs et
par secteur productif je dis bien là
l'industrie qui n'a pas de matières
premières pour pour travailler le
commerce et à savoir que 80 % de nos
rentrées sont du commerce extérieur
qu'on ne peut pas avoir s'il n'a pas un
fonds international qui va aider le
secteur privé comme vous l'avait dit
dans votre reportage au secteur
hospitalier
le secteur éducatif et je dis bien les
écoles et les universités sont en grands
déficits donc finalement on demande et
on va demander aux deux à hoarau de voir
aujourd'hui un support direct au secteur
privé j'espère sans passer par un état
parce qu'on peut plus passer par un état
qui ne va pas refaire d'autres
structures où il ya les mêmes personnes
j'espère de tout coeur que la communauté
internationale
je vais dit bien dire ne va pas faire
les mêmes erreurs donc financer un état
déficitaire et corrompu mais plutôt
financer les secteurs productifs en
direct comme la france a très bien monté
le très bon exemple il y a quelques
jours on est optimiste de cette visite
mais on espère qu'on aura un support
direct aux entreprises parce que si on
perd le secteur privé on va perdre la
croissance et il faudra des décennies
pour la reconstruire
si on perd notre application rapidement
il ya eu des manifestations et qui ont
encore eu lieu récemment dans un pays où
on l'a dit où près de la moitié de la
population vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
le soulèvement populaire contre le
pouvoir et la classe politique ne semble
pas être stoppée par les crises
économiques et sanitaires doit-on
craindre que le chaos politique viennent
aggraver la situation du pays finalement
regardé finalement cette recette crise
et la crise sociale
comme vous l'avait bien dit finalement
mais les personnes n'ont même plus
d'argent à aller dans les hôpitaux on a
en banque de mes deux médicaments on a
un manque de fuel d'essence donc oui
évidemment on craint une crise sociale
encore plus donc des mouvements
révolutionnaires encore plus ils peuvent
s'aggraver et même devenir agressif sur
le terrain parce que quand on arrive sur
ce seuil de pauvreté que vous avez bien
dit qui dépasse 50% de la population
je vais ajouter certains chiffres on a
plus de 38 % de chômeurs on a des
entreprises plus que 25 % des
entreprises du secteur privé qui sont en
train de fermer chaque jour on a les
entreprises pour rester en vie et
finalement on voit la moitié pour ne pas
dire les trois quarts de leurs employés
on a des employés qui touchent 20 ou 30
% de leur salaire
on a un pouvoir d'achat est tombé de 75
% parce qu'on a eu une déflation total
de la livre libanaise et en même temps
un coût de vie qui a été augmenté de
500% donc ça coûte 5 fois plus donc
imaginer que si on met ces chiffres-là
la crise sociale donc oui on craint un
éclatement sociale bien sûr on l'écrit
les révolutions plus grande mais le plus
important est j insiste c'est connu une
restructuration totale des réformes qui
sont suivis par des instances
internationales par le fonds monétaire
par la france par les pays donateurs
pour nous comme tous ensemble on ne
refasse pas les mêmes erreurs qui ont
été faits dans le passé
c'est vrai qu'on est un merci merci
beaucoup x 2 merkel d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président du rassemblement de dirigeants
et chefs d'entreprise ivan est dans le
monde